foreign
does okay so you're somebody I've
watched from afar
and I've actually had this thought over
and over
does that guy go home every day and be
like well I gotta do this one now like
because you you you on your show
you're talking to high achiever After
High achiever After High achiever After
High achiever and as soon as I meet a
high achiever I'm always like well I'm
gonna try that too I want to try that
too and I I I've thought without ever
knowing you that's got to be exhausting
like every ride home has to be like well
I guess I need to move everything to
crypto and the next one you're like well
I guess I need to move everything back
into cash and I need to try this workout
let's work out this workout
here's the question I begin to ask
myself
very similar I haven't been to to uh to
uh India or Iceland but but have
followed very similar yes you just go to
the university and study like a like a
research exactly I sit in my pool tub
which is a like a like a a true science
room and just a trough I bought at a
tractor supply for 100 bucks
um
at what point are we running still we've
just found a new thing to chase I don't
think it's running I think it's
um our pursuit of yeah I think it's
trying things on and seeing what works
for us okay it's I'm always because I
struggle with that because I'm always
going with this idea if I got to get
somewhere to the next level or the next
layer whatever words you want to use and
I'm starting to step back and look at
some of the great thinkers that I still
read now and they almost hit a
de-evolution process right it almost
went the other way well I don't think
there's fulfillment without growth okay
I think we've got to be growing in some
way that could be learning that could be
reading that could be
um you know trying new skills it could
be playing games and like doing stuff
we've got to be growing in some way I
think in order to feel fulfillment and
feel like okay I'm I'm do I'm not being
complacent okay I'm not saying you have
to always be striving for the next thing
but I think growth and contribution are
a huge part of fulfillment when I'm
learning when I'm growing and developing
as a human
and I'm also contributing to someone
else's life there's a lot more
fulfillment in that process as opposed
to I've stopped growing I'm not growing
at all I'm just going to stay where I'm
at and not learn anything new not tried
anything new and I'm just going to do
exact same things that's the thing that
haunts me is there a moment when growth
becomes cancer right when it's obsessive
growth yeah
what is it tied to your contributions
so it's grow I mean it's contribution
service for me it's all about service
but
and so when I'm doing interviews
and I'm
learning new things a lot of it's just
confirming that I'm doing the right
things okay that I'm on the path that
like okay you're just saying something
in a different way that I'm already
doing good I think for someone like me
and others we need constant reminders to
stay on track of doing the right things
no you know it's like a lot of us I got
it right a lot of us know what to eat
and that's going to make you healthy
then know how to work out right they
know they need to move their body and
eat well and sleep better as a a night
and get good rest but for whatever
reason we don't follow through on it
consistently right as a society based on
results
so it's just about having the consistent
lessons the inspiration the the wisdom
hurt in a different way to keep me on
track of like okay I'm I'm doing the
path I'm being consistent I'm being
disciplined on the path that I'm taking
and it's like oh let me try this
different style of breathing technique
maybe that can help me in a stressful
moment okay I'm gonna try this box
breathing technique that's a 60-second
thing and try it on maybe it works maybe
it doesn't people can say a lot of
different things to try these things and
maybe there's like okay I haven't tried
this thing yet or I just forgot
that I'm not I haven't done this in a
while and I need to get back to this
thing you know what I mean but that
almost makes it equal as important as
the info
the relationship 100 like the
interaction 100 man and that's what you
talked about in your book The Story of
relationships I think it was that
chapter connection which is about like
you have friend you have like people you
text but they're not your close friends
anymore you have people that were like
friends
but an in-person interaction became a
phone call became a text between became
a I'll get back to you later yeah and um
it's about the interactions we have with
the people in our lives and how we're
making an impact and being in service to
those people to them being empowered and
winning as well and that's the
difference between success and greatness
success success is self-section yeah
it's all about me let me accomplish this
let me achieve this goal let me win let
me look good let me be a bestseller
there's nothing wrong or bad with the
success but success by itself without
the impact and service to others in that
Pursuit will leave us feeling it's
unfulfilled yeah so greatness is more
about going after your dreams with your
unique gifts and talents in the season
of life you're in
but empowering those around you and the
great Kobe Bryant said this when I
interviewed him he was like greatness is
about
essentially being an inspiration to the
people around you and inspired them to
be great and when they are great they're
going to inspire others to be great and
it's about that Ripple that impact of
service through your talent through your
gift through your creativity and
whatever that is and and I realized that
most of my life was being successful for
me to feel good
yeah it was a win-lose mentality yep and
nobody wins unless everyone wins right
right and I didn't understand that
concept until 30 until I had breakdown
after breakdown after breakdown and I
learned for the first time the concept
of win-win at 30. as an athlete growing
up there was only one winner and
everyone else was a loser and that meant
when I lost it didn't feel good yeah and
I did everything to win
things that that like I just drove
myself crazy to win and then I still
didn't feel enough and that's when I
started shifting 10 years ago I created
a show called the school of greatness
that wasn't about me it was about others
and I said I'm gonna go on a journey and
humble myself and I'm going to interview
all the experts and Shine the Light on
others and just ask questions and humble
myself and it's been a decade of
consistently doing that and that the
picture there that you're painting is is
beautiful when it comes to greatness
because I'm hearing in this one
conversation
very few people can say when I was
talking to Kobe that one time
but there's greatness on the basketball
court and there's greatness that his
legendary greatness in the gym right
like behind closed doors so nobody's
watching
and then there's greatness of Life a
young man yeah rocking back and forth
and put his head down and walking up the
front of a small group and saying this
happened yeah right and it's that it's
everywhere in between right and the The
Men Who went home and talked to their
families for the first time or talk
called the counselor for the first time
right greatness the spectrum is so
powerful yeah right that Ripple effects
it doesn't matter the the the magnitude
of what you want to do in life it's not
greatness is not about
curing cancer or winning a world
championship it's about pursuing your
unique gifts and talents
and in that Pursuit making a difference
on the people around you in a positive
way it's not about
even accomplishing the pursuit although
yes we want to accomplish our goals and
things like that but just because the
dreams don't come true sometimes doesn't
mean your life and the experience wasn't
a dream come true doesn't mean what you
learned in the process wasn't a dream
yeah yeah it's amazing man so we got to
learn to
um interpret it and have a different
perspective around what it looks like
and also know that we are all in
different seasons of life
and you might be in one season uh for
three months or two years that you don't
want to be in but you're trying to get
out of and then it's going to expand to
something bigger and greater for the
next season but you needed that
challenging season to get to the next
stage and the The Challengers to hang on
hang on because the next stage is coming
right